joining us right now somebody that
rarely calls nancy pelosi senator tom
cotton senator welcome tonight at nine
o'clock the house is going to vote on
something on your bipartisan bill we
think
even though some of our reports said
they won't on a bipartisan bill do you
think it'll happen
i i don't know brian i can confirm that
i was not on the other side of that
phone call with nancy pelosi last night
i think the house is going to have to
vote so late tonight because nancy
pelosi and her radical democratic left
around looking for the tree around the
capital on which all this free money
grows brian i mean joe manchin put it
well today
they want to transform this country with
their socialist agenda i mean between
the 2 trillion dollar bill they passed
in march the trillion dollar
infrastructure bill they want now and
even if you go with joe manchin's
proposed 1.5 trillion dollar welfare
bill that would still be four and a half
trillion dollars of spending brian
that's taxes on every family in america
that's spending for illegal aliens and
dead welfare for deadbeats who won't
even look for work much less work
i think the democrats are realizing just
how unpopular their agenda is and that's
one reason why nancy pelosi is
struggling to corral those votes senator
i just so people should know i i risk
confusing people there's two separate
bills
so
the so-called moderates say i want the
bipartisan bill the senate passed you
didn't vote for it but 19 other
republicans did and the moderates said
nancy pelosi do it by the 27th of
september well it's september 30th and
they're going to vote today if they
don't vote for it kirsten cinema and
other moderate says they're out when it
comes to the 3.5 or any other compromise
so if they don't have the vote tonight
even if it fails the moderates balk if
they do have the vote the liberals don't
vote for it so nancy gets a fail joe
biden gets a loss at least temporarily
are they willing to risk that
yeah brian you laid it out pretty well i
would say the democratic party is in
disarray but i don't want to imply that
they were ever in a raid this gang right
now couldn't organize a one-car funeral
but the one thing they can all agree on
is they want to take more of your money
and give it away for their priorities
like welfare for illegals so you should
never count the democrats out no matter
how bad it looks for them while they're
making the sausage in the end what they
care more about is taking your money and
getting more power so you do believe uh
that something's going to come out of
this
did it shock you that in august joe
manchin put a pen to paper and handed
one pager to chuck schumer and said i'm
not going to pay i'm not going to go
along with 3.5 but i'll go along with
1.5 i won't actually sign off on
anything until october 1st so every time
they were talking about the 3.5 what
does joe manchin want they knew exactly
what he wanted but just chuck schumer
wouldn't talk about it bring me behind
the scenes there into the cloak room
what's happening
well first off brian i've never seen
such a document in my entire political
life no it's not as long as chuck
schumer's or joe manchin's but whenever
we have our differences we talk them out
we don't sign
uh contracts it was weird with each
other but second uh i think i think
chuck schumer has some explaining to do
to his fellow democrats as you pointed
out joe biden's been pretty or joe
manchin's been pretty upfront with him
from the beginning now i strongly
disagree with what senator manchin
proposed in that memo but chuck
schumer's known about it now for a
couple months yet he's been leading on
the far left of his caucus to believe
that they were still going to go for
broke with a 3.5 trillion dollar bill in
fact i'm beginning to wonder if maybe
chuck schumer is hearing some footsteps
from alexandria ocasio-cortez in the new
york primary next year right
real quick uh page 168 of this 2000 page
bill they are going to look to up vac
enforcement fines from seventy thousand
to seven hundred thousand that will
destroy so many small businesses you
can't even count them and the irs goes
on steroids if you think they're just
going after uh amazon you're dreaming
they're going after small business final
thought
yeah all these efforts to supercharge
the bureaucracy whether it's turning
small businesses into joe biden's covid
police force
or giving the irs tens of billions of
dollars to come after small businesses
just an effort to put more hands in the
powers of bureaucrats in washington
we'll keep you up to date if there's
going to be a vote tonight or not but it
doesn't look like it there is it'll pass
but who knows senator tom cotton thanks
so much thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else